it seems that every wind of doctrine is
blowing out there that there are those who
believe that jesus is not god that the
holy spirit is not part of the godhead
spiritual formation and mindfulness etc etc
what advice would you give to those who don't
want to be caught up or carried away in
these winds of doctrines study the bible
this is your only defense the worst deceptions
will come from within the church in the book of
acts paul is speaking to the elders of ephesus
he speaks from verse 17 onward he's speaking to
them for the rest of that chapter and in verse
28 he said take heed therefore unto yourselves
and unto the flock over the which the holy ghost
hath made you overseers to feed the church of god
or the flock of god which he hath purchased with
his own blood for i know this acts 17 29 acts
20 29 that after my departing shall grievous
rules enter in among you not sparing the flock
also of your own self shall man arise speaking
perverse things to draw away disciples after them
now he tells them in verse 32 i commend you to
god and to the word of his grace which is able
to build you up build up your spiritual immunity
your defense against deception is the word of god
study the word and as a seventh-day adventist we
are privileged to have the writings of ellen white
inspired counsel read her writings read desire of
ages when you talk about the divinity of christ
and discover for yourself the bible first
inspiration second uh of ellen white and c
get the answers and the defense against
this anti-trinitarianism this 25 20
christ at the beginning whatever else people
try to teach you will you will arm yourself
with the information you need because every
single person must eventually be able to stand
for himself and herself and determine what is
truth what is error you must be able to know that
so when the disciples came to christ in matthew
24 3 tell us when shall these things be and what
shall be the sign of thy coming and of the end
of the world jesus said to them take heed that no
man deceive you that's the first thing he said do
not let people deceive you and i have seen people
deceived right out of the church and my heart is
broken i still pray for them but to the day that
they'll come back deceived right out of the church
study god's word it is your only defense again
a phd does not protect you from error it is
the word of god not only studied but obeyed
so it works in your heart as a divine
principle that sustains you amen
prayer father and heaven we want to thank you and
praise you for this opportunity where we could
look into your word your word hath said to that
we may study to show ourselves approved unto you
rightly dividing the word of truth father give
us that impression give us that desire to study
your word to know the word of god personally and
individually we thank you father for brother randy
skeet that you have uh lend him here and send
him here to preach your word what a blessing
and it was and father i just pray that you will
be with him for the remainder of this weekend
be with all of us father may we be closer knitted
to you and desiring to follow you and to be a
light unto this world we ask all these things
now in the precious and powerful name of jesus
amen
you